ravi de vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo nous sommes au
coeur du parlement européen à bruxelles
et vous êtes bien sur les chaînes
parlementaires et la rtbf pour ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo consacrer
intégralement aux conséquences du
référendum britannique les botanique qui
ont choisi à majorité de sortir de
l'union européenne mais concrètement
comment est-ce que cela peut se passer
je vous propose un petit état des lieux
avant de vous présenter nos invités
david cameron premier ministre à la tête
d'un pays en sursis
le britannique par qui le référendum du
brds excité arriver à retrouver ses
partenaires pour un dîner de travail
transformée en séance d'explications
après le vote des britanniques qui ont
choisi à près de 52% de quitter l'union
européenne le vote a bien eu lieu mais
le pays semble maintenant peu pressé de
prendre le chemin de la sortie
david cameron a laissé entendre qu'il
prendrait son temps avant d'utiliser
l'article 50 du traité européen qui
permet à un état de quitter l'union
réunis en urgence à bruxelles le
parlement européen a demandé au
royaume-uni d'activer immédiatement
cette clause de retrait prévu dans le
traité de lisbonne pour éviter à
l'europe de plongée dans l'incertitude
c'est très énervé le président de la
commission européenne a mis la grande
bretagne devant ses responsabilités
je demande au gouvernement du royaume
uni et je verrai le premier ministre
plus tard dans la matinée qui reste un
ami parce que les britanniques restent
nos amis en dépit du vote qu'il fut le
leur je lui demanderais déclare il fait
le plus rapidement possible la situation
nous ne pouvons pas nous installer dans
une incertitude plonge une majorité de
pays emmené par la france presse londres
de préparer son départ au plus vite la
responsabilité c'est de ne pas perdre de
temps de ne pas perdre de temps ni pour
traiter convenablement la question du
départ du royaume-uni pas perdre de
temps non plus pour traiter la question
de la nouvelle impulsion que nous devons
donner à l'union européenne donc à 27
paris et berlin sont fermes à l'égard du
partenaire britannique
pas question d'avoir une europe à la
carte a prévenu la chancelière allemande
et européenne sur ude star que nous
l'union européenne est assez forte pour
surmonter le départ de la grande
bretagne
elle est assez forte pour continuer à
aller de l'avant même à 27 membres
elle est assez forte pour représenter
ses intérêts dans le monde
le break site pourrait-il faire pschitt
le pays sortant qui ne voulait pas
sortir fait durer le suspense et
l'europe restent suspendus à la décision
britannique sous l'oeil des marchés
financiers
voilà pour ce petit état des lieux sur
les conséquences du break site nous
sommes avec deux députés européens linda
mcavan bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
eurodéputé britannique
vous avez été élu sous les couleurs du
libellé parties de travailler c'est vous
siégez ici au sein du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates
et en face de vous andré h fab vous êtes
député allemand du groupe parti
populaire européen on va entendre
pendant ces 26 minutes votre sentiment
vos conclusions vos idées pour la suite
de l'europe c'est d'abord peut-être une
question avoue linda mcavan quand vous
avez pris connaissance du résultat du
vote quel a été votre premier sentiment
comment vous vous sentez tout simplement
aujourd'hui en tant qu'eurodéputé
britannique plutôt profil beaucoup de
tristesse parce que tristesse qu'on va
quitter l'union européenne un projet que
je crois est un grand succès quand on
pense à l'histoire de l'europe
on voit que c'est une grand succès
donkey l'union européenne mais aussi
parce qu on a eu une campagne chez nous
qu'il faut diviser les gens les jeunes
par rapport aux parents des jeunes de
d'origine immigrés d'autres familles
dont beaucoup beaucoup de divisions dans
notre société parce que c'était presque
50% 50% va quitter l'europe pour vous ce
processus est entamé il est irréversible
il n'y a pas de way back de marche en
arrière possible
je crois que c'est difficile on fait un
référendum
les gens votent par les mains non de
refaire référendum je crois que les gens
n'accepterai pas ça andré h fab le break
site comment on gère ça maintenant est
ce que les britanniques sont voués à
quitter l'union européenne après ce vote
je suis aussi un peu triste et aussi un
peu confus car la grande bretagne a
toujours été un grand pays qui a été
bénéficiaire pour le marché unique mais
qui a aussi bénéficié du marché unique
et je peux pas encore vraiment
comprendre comment ce vote a pu se faire
mais je pense que jean claude juncker
après très bien exprès
mais notre position les britanniques
restent nos amis ils sont nos voisins
mais on prend acte de leurs décisions
vous êtes un peu encore sous le choc de
ce vote
mais pourtant les choses s'organisent au
conseil européen réuni en un moment
françois hollande un gala merkel dit il
faut faire vite il faut gérer maintenant
les conditions de la sortie du royaume
au niveau dit il faut faire vite
ou au contraire essayer d' accorder un
peu de temps à londres
je crois que ça doit être difficile pour
nos partenaires à comprendre que ceux
qui ont mené la campagne pour quitter
l'union européenne n'ont aucune idée de
comment il va me faire ils ne sont pas
d'accord
donc c'est ça le problème et maintenant
david cameron il a donné il a donné les
ses licenciés du premier comme premier
ministre donc il restera seulement
quelques semaines il dit c'est celui qui
qui va le succès dès qu'il va prendre la
décision dont nous en tant qu'opposition
on a on a fait la campagne pour rester à
l'unisson l'union européenne
et c est mais c'est le gouvernement qui
doit dire ce qu'ils veulent je co et
c'est ça le problème
ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est pour cela que les autres
maintenant doivent attendre mais je
comprends l'irritation de juncker et des
autres leaders alors on va demander
l'avis peut-être de jean arthuis bonjour
vous avez rejoint bonjour bardet moi je
présidais de la collection de nature
alors vous êtes député français
eurodéputés français de l'alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux pour l'europe
votre réaction à ce qui est en train de
se passer notamment conseil européen qui
essayent de presser les britanniques de
sortir le fameux article 50 qui prévoit
une sortie de l'union européenne est ce
que l'europe doit être ferme à l'égard
du partenaire britannique ou au
contraire lui laisser un peu de temps
mais je crois que l'europe doit être
conséquente
on voit bien que l'europe est à
l'épreuve qu'elle souffre qu'elle ne
répond pas complètement à la tente des
européens et une europe qui ne ne parle
pas vraiment aux européens et une europe
qui donne l'impression que au fond les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement se
réunissent périodiquement à bruxelles
pour régler entre eux leurs petites
affaires et prolongez d'illusions et
qu'ils auraient encore en main la
plénitude de leurs prérogatives de
souveraineté est malheureusement trop
souvent ils donnent en spectacle leur
impuissance politique et c'est cela qui
fait l'incompréhension l'exaspération
des citoyens le populisme et leurs
phobies et quand ça va pas c'est la
faute de l'union européenne ça ne peut
pas continuer ainsi
l'europe a besoin d'être gouvernée or
pour l'instant il n'y a pas vraiment de
pilote dans l'avion
nous sommes confrontés à des défis
majeurs celui des migrations au
déclenchement desquels l'europe a été un
peu impliqués qui est allé en irak en
2003 en libye et puis en syrie
faut assumer les conséquences de ce que
l'on a accompli et on voit bien qu aucun
état à lui seul ne peut régler les
conséquences dont nous avons besoin
d'europe d'une europe qui définisse son
cap et qui avance et qui devient une
puissance mondiale
alors on a on ne peut pas continuer avec
les britanniques qui bien souvent en
être ont bloqué le dispositif vous par
les blocages alors justement ce sera ma
question pour vous rendrez h fab il ya
toutes ces crises qui bloque un peu le
cours de l'europe
et maintenant il ya c'est ce dossier
britannique qui vient se rajouter à
l'agenda européen
les britanniques ont deux ans c'est ce
que prévoit le traité de lisbonne pour
organiser leur sortie mais on dit que ce
divorce pourrait prendre 10 ans est ce
que pendant ce temps là l'europe ne va
pas une fois de plus être bloquée
pendant le temps d'organisation de
divorce non c'est un c'est un moment
difficile c'est clair que nous voulons
éviter que l'europe soit bloquée et
c'est pour cette raison c'est seulement
pour cette raison que le chef de l'état
ont demandé à la grande-bretagne
d'utiliser maintenant les conséquences
de ce comptable pas avoir deux ans pour
réfléchir
il est clair qu'il ya un processus de
deux ans pour discuter de négocier mais
malheureusement de mon point de vue le
peuple britannique a décidé de se
séparer de l'europe et cette décision
elle est là on n'a pas besoin de temps
pour l'interpréter mais si londres
tarder à utiliser cet article 50
quelques qu'est ce qui peut se passer
on va trouver des eaux va trouver des
réponses à ça c'est clair qu'il ya
maintenant une nouvelle réalité
politique même si le premier ministre
britannique n'a pas encore mise en
oeuvre l'article 50 pour l'instant linda
mcavan vous qui êtes aux députés
britanniques pour vous siégez ici à
bruxelles comment ça peut se passer pour
vous concrètement c'est à dire que vous
allez continuer de siéger au nom de
votre pays qui à terme et est voué à
sortir de l'europe comment est ce
possible une annonce un peu c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire que ceci
se passe on ne sait pas grand chose pour
l'instant je crois que c'est le devoir
du premier ministre qui arrivera au mois
de septembre
u 9 septembre qui doit maintenant
déclencher le processus
donc il peut pas il aurait elle ne peut
pas attendre parce que on a pris une
décision et des deux côtés de la
décision de vous les partenaires et le
peuple britannique qu'ils ont voté donc
je crois qu'ils vont commencer
ils vont déclencher sa et à partir du
moment où on commence à faire des
négociations je crois que le reste
viendra claire et même j'espère que dans
entre temps le plus important c'est
l'économie de l'hérault et c'est dans
l'intérêt de personne d'avoir une
économie faible en europe et donc il
faut là il faut la certitude pour tout
le monde
il faut pas plus de certitudes et pour
d'autres députés pour notamment nigel
farage qu'on a vu ce mardi lors de la
séance il avait d'ailleurs été
interpellé par le présent la commission
européenne est ce que lui et son et le
groupe qu'ils s'agissaient doit doit que
doivent quitter ce qu'ils doivent
quitter leur siège n'est pas question de
de tenir la grande bretagne parce qu'il
faut préparer des relations de
partenariat l'europe est aussi la grande
bretagne
la grande bretagne a souhaité par son
peuple ne pas rester dans l'union
européenne mais nous restons des
partenaires et donc il faut trouver un
nouveau chemin de nouvelles conventions
on y arrivera ils sont conscients
qu'elle quelle convention pour parler de
convention
la convention commerciale on en a bien
avec la norvège avec la suisse avec la
turquie
donc on va bien trouver les conventions
mais ne perdons pas de temps que les
chefs d'état ne trouve pas là un
prétexte pour attendre pour acheter du
temps une fois encore parce que je vous
rend attentif au fait qu'on est bloqué
depuis le mois de février
je cameron avait demandé des conditions
extravagantes
il voulait que dans les traités on dit
bien que l'avenir de l'europe ce n'était
pas une union plus hilare il a obtenu
gain de cause sur chacun ça c'est fini
et moi ce qui m'a étonné c'est que
monsieur tusk et négocier une telle
disposition est que nos chefs d'état et
de gouvernement les ai acceptées et au
parlement européen depuis le mois de
février on décide plus rien on ne dit
plus rien parce que il fallait attendre
le référendum britannique
bon ça y est on en est sorti je crois
que maintenant il faut aller de l'avant
sinon sinon l'europe va se disloquer
il faudrait pas non plus que les
demandes très particulière cette europe
à la carte que souhaitaient les
britanniques servent de référence à
d'autres pays d'europe centrale pour
revendiquer je ne sais quelle
considération particulière
ça n'est pas comme ça qu'on va préparer
l'avenir est-ce qu'il faut compter sur
le couple franco allemand notamment sur
l'allemagne
oui bien sûr le coureur allemand joue un
rôle clé mais il est clair que ce que
jean arthuis a clairement dit elle la
nouvelle réalité politique en europe
c'est que cette offre à la grande
bretagne et qu'on avait fait avant le
référendum
elle est fini maintenant lors du ce fait
faire un cadre exceptionnel de mon point
de vue il est aussi clair que le rabais
britannique que c'était le seul rabais
d'un seul pays et aussi fini mais vous
pensez que les britanniques sont prêts à
entendre ça c'est pour ça que je le dis
ce sont habitués pendant nous ne sommes
des amis que le son départ de l'air nord
mali jean arthuis on reste amis on veut
coopérer ensemble mais l'europe ça se
partage pas on peut pas choisir ce qu'on
veut l'europe c'est pour tous ou pour
rien et donc les exceptions que les
britanniques
on tue les exceptions qu'on a discuté
avec cameron avant c'est maintenant fini
on veut aller ensemble au delà de tout
ça et je pensais aussi un message très
clair qu'il faut donner pour les états
membres qui reste dans l'union
européenne c'est quand même 27
c'est quand même mal fait alors en
attendant je vous propose de regarder un
petit reportage dans les rues de londres
notamment où
beaucoup de britanniques ont le blues
ils ont voté et beaucoup ont des regrets
et surtout ils reprochent à certains des
responsables qui ont mené la campagne du
président d'avoir menti
regardez ce petit sujet signe estime
martel
des lendemains qui déchantent au royaume
uni vendredi
les britanniques se sont réveillés dans
un pays divisé de la rue aux plateaux
télé l'attention des débats ne retombe
pas générations les jeunes qui ont voté
pour rester dans l'europe ont
l'impression que les plus âgés leur ont
volé leur avenir
beaucoup de jeunes quand ça ils ne sont
pas venus voter s'ils étaient si
intéressé par la démocratie il serait
venu noter qu'une partie de la
population refuse toujours le verdict
des urnes
une pétition pour un nouveau référendum
recueil plusieurs millions de signatures
une autre propose que londres sa
sécession pour rester dans l'union
européenne
même les leaders du out semblent
tétanisés par le résultat boris johnson
chef de file des progressistes se
contente d'une brève déclaration il n'y
a pas de précipitation à avoir comme l'a
dit le premier ministre
rien ne va changer comme pour minimiser
la portée du référendum avant de
disparaître des écrans radars
seul nigel farrage chef d'un parti
ouvertement europhobe clame haut et fort
sa victoire et entend peser dans les
négociations avec bruxelles mais il est
rattrapé par ses promesses de campagne
de quoi faire déchanter les électeurs
qui ont choisi le bric site
chez les pro européens on cherche des
responsables au parti travailliste
le leader jérémie corby nette accusée de
ne pas avoir suffisamment mouiller la
chemise pendant la campagne
malgré la fronde il annonce qu'il ne
démissionnera pas vous savez ce sont les
gens en bas de l'échelle qui vont
souffrir et nous devons être leur
porte-parole
nous ne devrons pas nous embarquer dans
des querelles de leadership je suis
vraiment cela me laisse vraiment sans
voix c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
pour ajouter à la confusion les cosses
fait entendre sa voix la première
ministre a immédiatement remis sur la
table l'objectif de sa vie
l'indépendance ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il n'ya pas de crise de pouvoir en
écosse en tant que premier ministre je
vais faire tout mon possible pour éviter
que l'ecosse ne sorte de l'union
européenne car les conséquences pour
nous sera désastreuse elle promet un
autre référendum
les écossais devrait se prononcer pour
ou contre leur sortie du royaume uni une
difficulté supplémentaire pour les
prochains dirigeants de la future grande
bretagne indépendante
alors linda mcavan secondes incroyable
cette séquence qu'on a vu surtout que
les télévisions européennes de nigel
farage qui reconnaît que ces promesses
était fausse
est-ce que ça mérite des sanctions c'est
difficile en effet si les sanctions
contre les campagnes politiques et même
des mensonges gros mais il avait dit
plein de choses
j'ai entendu daniel hannan qui était qui
est député européen qui avait qui avait
dit dans l'immigration ceinture que de
débat et à la télévision samedi dit non
on ne peut pas garantir que
l'immigration va baisser saison derrière
tous ces gens toutes ces choses qu'ils
ont dit maintenant c'est vrai que les
gens s'en vont se fâcher les gens qui
ont voté pour parce qu'ils ont voté pour
parce qu'ils pensaient que on dépense
rolando trop d'argent dans l'union
européenne
ils ont même même les chiffres étaient
mauvais j'aime les chiffres donc mais
c'est difficile on a fait la campagne on
a fait le dit le contraire mais les
organes y est ce qu'il ya une
irresponsabilité de certains
responsables de partis britanniques
j'enlève de l'union européenne et ce
qu'elle ne parle pas aux européens je
préside la commission des budgets
ce budget n'a pas de vraie signification
ils ne représentent que 1% du produit
intérieur brut européen
il est financé essentiellement par les
états membres mais seules ressources
propres sont des droits de douane et
comme on n'arrête pas de signer des
contrats de libre échange et droits de
douane fondent comme neige au soleil et
sur ce budget 80 % des crédits repartent
vers les états membres ce budget là
n'est pas explicable aux citoyens une
institution dont le budget n'est pas
explicable aux citoyens est une est une
institution en difficulté
le problème de l'europe c'est la
démocratie l'europe ne parle pas aussi
le voyage est d'ailleurs dans la
campagne très difficile de combattre les
arguments des populistes démagogues qui
peuvent dire des choses qui se font
parfois ils ne voient là disent
n'importe quoi
il n'importe quoi et l'europe vraiment
de discours donc c'est ça qu'il faut
construire maintenant il faut qu'on
sache très précisément ce que fait leur
et en quoi elle est utile pour les
européens andré à cheval sur les propos
de le faire assure qui est décrit est
clair les avantages de l'europe sont là
pour tout le monde mais malheureusement
c'est pas facile de les voir avec les
yeux et donc le problème que nous avons
c'est qu'on n'est pas arrivé assez à
communiquer dans pour les gens en grande
bretagne mais c'est la même chose en
france et en allemagne pour communiquer
ce qui est un avantage direct pour les
citoyens et là il faut qu'on s'y mettre
car ça serait quand même la question
principale pour le futur parce que les
partis populistes et les représentants
des partis populistes dont nigel farage
et arrive à communiquer avec charisme
sur au contraire les inconvénients de
nom parce que moi je n'en suis pas
convaincu que c'est la raison le
problème de l'europe c'est pas qu'elle
est faible
le problème c'est que nos adversaires
sont convaincus ignore les faits et nous
on n'a pas les moyens comme jean arthuis
à degli nous n'avons pas les moyens de
décrire ce que nous faisons pour mieux
pourquoi pour quelle raison que tout est
plié par exemple on ne parle pas
l'opinion publique européenne il ya eu
deux situations qui ont révulsé
l'opinion luc slicks panama people
comment se fait-il qu'ils étendent
évasion fiscale et on va condamner
google
ikea starbucks mcdonald's cia de
l'optimisation fiscale c'est parce que
les états européens se concurrencent
mutuellement la bêtise et les chez nous
ce débat là doivent avoir lieu sur
l'opinion publique alors pour faire
taire les scandales et dire que quand
même les politiques font quelque chose
les ministres des finances sont réunis à
peine deux semaines pour trouver un
accord pour lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale
ce type de débat intéresserait l'opinion
publique
ils se sont mis d'accord entre ministres
donc on va pas casser les pieds à
l'irlande qui a un taux de 12,7 euros
plat d'étain pensionnaires défenseur
peut-être que les tchèques ont un
problème de tva donc on se met d'accord
entre nous discréditer ces petits
arrangements presque secrètement il faut
se lancer le débat devrait avoir lieu au
parlement européen et l'opinion publique
des européens s'intéresserait rester bas
et ferait pression sur les états qui
essaient de près
hervé des petit avantage momentané donc
je pense qu'il ya un problème de débat
public et de démocratie il faut pas
qu'on s'occupe d'un tas de petites
choses réglementaire qui complique la
vie des gens bien souvent ils sont
incomprises sont des questions
fondamentales de souveraineté nous avons
un problème avec l'euro n'ont pas de
gouvernement dans la zone euro nous
avons un règlement de copropriété mais
qui n'est pas respecté et comme il n'est
pas respecté il n'y a même pas de
champion non plus donc on a pas de
règlement et on n'a pas de gouvernement
arrêtons cette cette confusion et ce
risque de délitement
alors en attendant il ya un risque de
délitement de toute l'europe mais il ya
aussi les amas kavanagh risque de
désunion et de délitement du royaume uni
lui-même parce que les écossais
maintenant souhaite plus que tout
rejoindre l'union européenne
comment vous réagissez à sa wii avec ce
serait une bonne chose
le premier ministre écossais elle
viendra à bruxelles pour parler je suis
déterminé c'est un grave problème en
irlande du nord
il y aura énormément de problèmes entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande où l'écart avec gerber
reprendre leur combat
oui c'est ça qui risque de j'espère que
non mais à des risques et à des risques
maintenant parce que ça cela va ouvrir
ouvrir tous les problèmes c'est le rock
qui nous a aidés à résoudre le problème
de l'irlande du nord et les problèmes du
terrorisme parce qu'on a pu aider
l'économie
maintenant on est dans une période
d'incertitude et on ne sait pas très
bien ce qui s'est passé très très vite
dans le hachoir comment l'europe éviter
ce risque majeur qui pèsent sur elle de
2 8 me de délitement dislocation il faut
une analyse strict du terme
il faut essayer de trouver une solution
avec les britanniques qui fait en sorte
qu' ils décident s'ils ont vraiment
décider rapidement et on trouvera des
moyens pour le pot le break 6 pour le
réellement faire il faut clairement
lancé le message que les exceptions
qu'il a eu pour les britanniques seront
finis maintenant pour toujours et si un
jour ils veulent revenir ça serait avec
le plus grand plaisir porter les
européens mais avec le la demande puis
s'assoit sur la base générale
est ce que vous pensez jean arthuis
congrès avait reculé françois hollande
qui vont affronter chacun des élections
dans leur propre pays en 2017 sont
capables de porter ce message là d'une
europe forte et unie où elle reste qu'au
contraire il faut du changement en
europe
je pense que tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui ne
porterait pas ce message vendre est une
chimère est une illusion
l'avenir de chacun des pays l'union
européenne
c'est forcément l'europe nous sommes
dans la mondialisation la mondialisation
a fait naître des risques majeurs une
crise financière peut être un véritable
tsunami économique et social dégradation
des climats migration il faut organiser
le monde qui peut prétendre influencé
l'organisation du monde sinon l'union
européenne
donc je pense que nos projets et pour
créer de l'emploi et pour donner de la
sécurité
lutter contre le terrorisme y'a que
l'europe qui peut le perdre mais chacun
son projet notamment à la droite il ya
certains comme nicolas sarkozy ou non le
maire qui propose des référendums est-ce
que c'est avant tout référendum
commençons par débattre avec les
européens à poser des problèmes sur la
place publique en disant voilà qu'est ce
qui peut être fait efficacement par
l'état part par l'état nation est ce que
pour ces questions là il faut continuer
à faire croire que l'état nation petit
arriver ou bien est-ce que ce serait
plus utile de le traiter collectivement
au plan européen
c'est vrai pour l'emploi c'est vrai pour
la sécurité c'est vrai pour les
migrations c'est vrai pour les climats
c'est vrai pour lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux contre les fraudes
fiscales
regardez la suisse la suisse avait le
secret bancaire
quand les américains se sont hachées ça
a duré huit jours mais les européens
n'ont pas été foutus de définir une
position commune par rapport à la suisse
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que nous acceptons d'être des nains
politiques est ce que demain on ne peut
pas durer
alors est ce que demain à 27 ludion peut
marcher et se redéfinir sans le
partenaire britannique
j'ai pris d'un aigle a toujours eu leur
leurs opinions leurs avis spéciale il
mais c'est clair autant je suis d'accord
avec jean arthuis que toutes ces
questions doivent se
sur la table je pense aussi qu'il faut
des nouveaux compromis
on n'a pas besoin de plus de démocratie
peut-être les ministres devraient ce
revenu en public d'accord mais on a
besoin de trouver les meilleurs
compromis sur la fiscalité sur l'emploi
et sur l'euro et tout ça et ça sera
cruelle est difficile car c'est pas
toujours la même chose que les peuples
français et allemands d'attendre que ça
veut dire pas une énième réunion qui
finissent par déboucher sérieux ça veut
dire qu'ils doivent se mettre autour de
la table et non sans relever que quand
ils ont pris à des décisions ça vous dit
on va voir peut-être une main à un mot
de conclusion parce qu'on arrive à au
terme de cette émission avoue linda
mcavan un message d'espoir peut-être ou
deux oui je dirai à mes collègues de
faire attention aux populistes aux
slogans assez facile à dire un spectacle
contrôle qui ne veut rien dit qui veut
tout dire etc et donc faire attention au
référendum parce que les gens ne
répondent jamais les questions qu'on le
pose
ils répondent à nos questions et pour
l'avenir je crois on va voir ce qui se
passera chez nous je crois des gens et
beaucoup qui seront comme maintenant
qu'il faut il ya beaucoup de problèmes
dans ce monde où il faut travailler
ensemble pour les résoudre j'espère que
le royaume uni même qu'ils n'aient même
qui sera pas membre de l'union va
pouvoir continuer à travailler avec les
autres pays
et c'est dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
de trouver de solution eh bien on se
reverra d'ici là pour en parler sans
doute merci à vous trois d'avoir animé
cette émission avec moi je vous souhaite
une très bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et sur la
rtbf bail